you're saying our daughter from the
future named Nora
after your mother kind of stuck here now
anybody know what to do my whole life
has been out of order no I shouldn't be
here
oh these computers are you doing slower
than the ones that the flash museum did
you say Museum yeah
I studied everything this man is hiding
in the shadows you guys beat him at
least we're supposed to the time I
changed I need to send her home but you
guys have such a strong connection
in the future what happens to me
very
we don't stop this essential cities
gonna be a war zone
I'm sorry these things don't always go
the way you plan them hey everybody
happy New York comic-con week we got
surprise new flash footage they finally
revealed the flash Museum I knew they
were doing all the things this season
these computers are slower than the ones
at the flash Museum like apparently she
still thinks that the flash museum even
though it's super advanced in the future
has super slow computers there's a new
round of that DC streaming service
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a flash
related comment on the video the big
thing here is they're teasing the war
that's going to erupt over what cicada
is doing in Central City in Nora just
apologizing then filling in some
backstory you literally see how clingy
she is to Barry
you see Cisco lose his powers like this
is actually probably what's going on
because he's facing cicada with the
lightning bolt speed force dagger so
when he clutches his hand and they're
all like what's that sound what's going
on and you hear that brass be breathing
it's almost like angry helicopter
breathing with the way that it rattles
like if you've seen any of the predator
movies the way the predator makes that
crackling sound when it gets really
angry that's kind of the sound that
cicada is making through his respirator
that he wears when he's wearing his
costume I guess you could think of
cicada as kind of like the predator
since he's going after metas one at a
time the way they cut it is a little
misleading too when they start hyping
cicada going after everyone like they
really want you to think that he's going
to kill Joe this season remember Nora's
conversation with Joe in cecile last
season like enjoy the time you have
while you have it implying that they
would be dead in the future they said
the berry would be doing more classic
CSI work you see him doing a little bit
of that here he does that every day
that's his normal job when he's not the
flash so they just chosen not to show
that the last couple of seasons I love
the way that Nora talks about the flash
museum too if you guys didn't know it's
created in the not-too-distant future in
the comics it's around while Barry and
everyone else is alive it's featured
prominently in the flash rebirth book so
it's not like it's something that isn't
created till the vastly distant future
so we would have been built when Nora
was a little girl because you have to
imagine that she is born sometime in the
last season or two of the flash the
reason why she's joking about how slow
the computers are here compared to the
already slow computers in the flash
Museum is because she travels from 30
years in the future so like how fast is
your iPhone now compared to a phone from
say like four years ago it's vastly more
powerful so you just have to imagine
that in Nora's present day the computer
technology is crazy crazy fast
so obviously the flash museum has old
technology that the flash collected
while he was being the flash so we'd be
like you trying to go use an original
Macintosh from the 80s
it'd just be super slow this way I'm
hoping that in the hundredth episode
anniversary we actually get to
flash-forward or travel to the Future
briefly to see the flash Museum in the
flesh and give Barry some teasers about
what's going to come remember at the end
of season one when Barry traveled back
to try and save his mother and you got
all those teasers for killer frost then
the flash museum the easiest way for
them to do that again with even more
teasers for stuff to come is to give you
a vision of the flash Museum and then
you just see stuff in the background
like you see more robed costumes you see
Technology Barry maybe with the Justice
League like you see Oliver you see
Superman them all teamed up so just a
way to get you hyped for things that
they're intending on doing in future
seasons doesn't necessarily have to be
teasers for stuff that they're gonna pay
off right away because we learned about
Flash Museum at the end of season 1 nor
here in the trailer for season 5 episode
1 is the second time that they mentioned
flash museum so think about how much
time passes before they pay certain
things off there is a growing conspiracy
theory that still thinks that Nora is
fake and she's pretending to be Barry's
daughter and she's really someone else
like the reverse-flash or even his
granddaughter from further in the future
I have not seen compelling enough
footage or evidence to back those
theories yet like look at her face when
she's clinging to him here and screaming
dad the way they pitched the show is
kind of twisty but I don't think it's
that twisty like they want to give you
this awesome payoff Barry says my life
has always been out of order like he's
literally meeting his daughter before
they even conceived her they just got
married they joked a little bit about
having kids at the end of season 4 like
iris says one day it'll be our turn then
knock-knock-knock coincidence
just as they mentioning having a child
there
knocks on the door you get a whole bunch
more footage of cicada just looking
really menacing standing out over the
horizon of the city they make it a
little bit clearer that he lost one of
his children because he holds up some of
their clothing I love the fact that they
put berries Tachyon device on Nora to
try and get her back to the future it's
probably relatively early in the process
of them trying to figure out what to do
with her because she says I'm kind of
stuck here now do any of you have any
ideas Mary's probably like well you know
I've met a few speedsters from the
future that have been stuck here in the
present they used a couple different
ways to get back to the future so we'll
try what we did before
so he's doing the reverse-flash thing
and again you know a lot of people still
finding reverse-flash easter eggs in
here i still don't think that it's a
fake version of reverse-flash pretending
to be Nora just because of the links
they're going to with the color of her
lightning like remember last season when
they did iris with the purple lightning
berries Lightning was always a little
bit lighter shade I mean it wasn't
yellow Wally's was closer to yellow they
just really want you to think that she's
the combination of two different people
iris and Barry so that's why she has two
different colors of lightning there's
just a lot of visual clues they're
trying to give people that don't read
comics that's why it's so different from
the tornado twins of the comics but I
know you're all still holding out hope
that there's a twin brother in the
future somewhere because they're
changing the timeline so much anything
is possible also love the fact that she
tells Barry about him dying in the
future flash vanishes in crisis now
Barry probably has been reading this
newspaper for the past five years
knowing what it says but not really
understanding what happens also remember
the big Easter egg here this is
obviously written by iris but the
central city citizen is what iris is
blog is so she's gonna turn that into a
legit big newspaper in the future a big
news organization so it's more of them
pushing her in the Lois Lane direction
which is a little more comic-book
accurate what do you think people have
wanted in the past there's a couple
flashes of killer frost just reminding
you that they're gonna be paying that
off I've ever did a couple of videos
about her and the character that they've
cast to play her father who sounds like
he's gonna be icicle they're just a
reminder that this is dropping next week
so the flash is back Tuesday nights next
week obviously I'll do videos like I've
done in previous seasons post all your
reactions in the comments below say your
prayers
for Cisco because he's going to go back
to being regular Cisco 99% sure that
this is him losing his powers post all
your theories in the comments what's
happening tonight is as Mark Ruffalo is
going on Jimmy Fallon to accidentally
quote-unquote but totally on purpose
spoil something for Avengers for he
might be revealing the title so whatever
it is that Marvel is letting him spoil I
will totally do a video for that next
click here to rewatch that extended
aquaman trailer and click here for my
non-spoilery venom review thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
see you guys tonight
[Music]